foreign
[Music]
I'm an associate professor of
pharmacology and cancer biology at Duke
University and I'll be presenting today
some of our work on using functional
genomic tools to interrogate the changes
and functional properties of tumors
during the course of drug resistance
evolution
so our laboratory actually works in in
two related areas the first area that we
work in is to try to understand how
tumor context regulates survival
signaling in cancer specifically in this
area we're interested in understanding
how things like signaling and metabolic
pathways as well as the structure of
organelles like the mitochondria and
even drug treatment exposure impacts the
regulation of survival signaling in
cancer cells frequently these these
studies focus on the bcl2 family of
proteins in the mitochondria
the second area of work in our lab
focuses on functional tumor Evolution
and in this area of the lab what we're
really interested in is understanding
how the dependencies in tumor cells
change as those tumor cells progress
from a treatment naive state to an on
treatment minimal disease State
and and on further to a progressive
Frank resistant state
and the the vignettes that I described
today both fall under the umbrella of
this second research area in our lab
so today I'm going to describe two
stories from the lab that were recently
published the first is a study that
involves the concept that drugs can
actually exert not only detrimental
effects on cancer cells but also
potentially beneficial effects and if we
can separate out these beneficial and
detrimental effects we can potentiate
the activity of anti-cancer therapies
this work was published in nature cancer
in 2022
the Second Story I'm going to describe
is one that demonstrates that drug
therapies can select for clonal variants
in tumor cell populations that exhibit
exploitable collateral sensitivities and
this is work that was published in
nature genetics in 2020.
before I go any further I want to point
out that all of the studies I present
today
starting with the um the first story in
nature cancer were led by two
extraordinary students in my lab Kevin
Lin and Justine Rutter they were both
co-first authors on on both of the two
papers
and that these studies were also co-led
by my colleague and um close
collaborator Alex pushant who's at
insurm in the University of Paris
so in the first area we had we initiated
a study that was um motivated by the
hypothesis that drugs and in particular
drugs that that impact broad cellular
processes might exert not only
detrimental effects but also potentially
beneficial effects on the fitness of
cancer cells so to try to understand
what these effects might look like we
chose to work with the drug cell in exor
which is inhibitor of xpo1 a nuclear
exportant that is responsible for
shuttling protein cargo from this from
the nucleus into the cytoplasm
celinex or treatment of cancer cells
causes an inhibition of xpo1 function
and the nuclear sequestration of protein
clients
the we hypothesized that the nuclear
sequestration of some of these protein
clients might actually benefit the
fitness levels of cancer cells
so to unpack this we use two parallel
ohmics approaches in the top we used
traditional crispr cas9 based loss of
function screens to identify genes that
alter the sensitivity of cancer cells to
cell and explore treatment and on the
bottom we used reverse phase protein
arrays to understand the changes in
signaling pathway activities that are
observing cancer cells following
treatment with cell and exor
by combining the results of these two
omic analyzes we we hypothesized that we
could identify Pathways and processes
that are both activated by Sonic sore
treatment and whose activation benefits
cell Fitness
when we did this analysis and we looked
at our results one of the things that
stood out was that akt activation has
all the Hallmarks of a beneficial effect
of cellonexor
crispr screens showed that that
suppression of the pi3k akt pathway
sensitize cells to cellinexor whereas
forced activation for example by loss of
the tumor suppressor P10 confers
resistance to cell and xor
similarly we found that through
proteomic studies that treatment of AML
of ml cells with cell and exor leads to
the activation of the aqt pathway as
judged for example by activating
phosphorylation marks on akt at t308 and
s473
. together these lead to the model that
suggests that treatment of AML cells
with cell nextor leads to the activation
of akt signaling an effect which
promotes Fitness of these cells
to dig a little bit further we first
showed through flow cytometry studies
that akt activation is really a
deterministic effect of akt Activation
so in most if not all cells treated with
cell next door
exhibit an increase in akt Activation so
this is not the selection for minor
clones
and if you look across different AML
cell lines we find that akt activation
is a very common observation following
selenics or treatment
the activation of akt falling silencer
treatment is an On Target effect
associated with xpo1 inhibition and we
know that because if we knock out xpo1
using two different guide rnas we see
akt activation that phenocopies what we
see with the drug
to understand how akt is being activated
by silence or treatment we again turn to
Chris burke-based screening this time
using flow-based screening approaches
which basically involve first using
crispr to introduce mutations across all
coding genes in the genome then treating
that mutagenized population with
celinexor then flowing those cells
through a flow cytometer and capturing
those cells that have high or low levels
of akt phosphorylation where in
particular we were interested in gene
Knockouts that were enriched in the low
akt activation portion of this
distribution based on the reasoning that
cells that are unact able to activate
akt phosphorylation would be enriched in
those cells in which key components of
the signaling Machinery linking cell and
extra treatment with akt would have been
knocked out
when we looked at the data from this
from these screens
what we found were that while most genes
in the genome have no effect or or very
minor effects on akt phosphorylation a
handful of genes had dramatic effects
and interestingly many of those genes
are genes that we would associate with
the ECT pathway so for example akt1 into
itself
the gamma isoform of pi3 kinase
its cognate regulatory subunit pick 3r5
and on the other end of the distribution
P10 the negative regulator of pf3 County
signaling now one of the genes that was
most interesting to us was um the the
gpcr P2 ry2 which is a known potential
activator of akt signaling that signals
through pia3 kinase gamma and pick 3 R5
in the gpcr arm of pa3 County signaling
interestingly when we performed rna-seq
we found that selling store treatment
not only led to
activation of akt but also led to the
upregulation of P2 ry2 expression and
together these two pieces of data are
consistent with the model that the akt
activating function of cell next or
treatment might result from the
upregulation of p2ry2 that results from
drug treatment
we then showed that cell and XR induced
p2ry2 activation is not only is both
necessary and sufficient for The
observed akt Activation so for example
if you look across a panel of cell lines
we see consistent p2ry2 upregulation
following cellular treatment
further we show that if you block that
upregulation using crispr in this case
using doxycycline inducible shrnas we
can fully block akt activation following
cellular treatment
we can phenocopy this effect by using
either pertussis toxin which is a
general inhibitor of gpcr signaling or
Arc which is an inhibitor of p2ri2
and finally we show the p2ry2 activation
is sufficient for akt Activation by
showing that if we simply overexpress
p2ry2 we that we can observe akt
activation in cells
to further understand signaling
Downstream of p2ry2 that's leading to
akt activation we performed a series of
mechanistic studies which revealed that
p2ry2 driven akt activation requires
p101 gamma p101 and also Ras
so for example if you knock down PS3
kinase Gamma or its cognitive regulatory
subunit subunit Pick 3 R5 you block akt
activation
and similarly
if you suppress the the expression of
both k-ras and inras although
interestingly not either one on its own
you can similarly block akt activation
following um Sonics or treatment and
this is consistent with what is known
about the the role of wraths in
signaling um Downstream of piafra County
scamma
from a translational perspective we were
able to observe that inhibiting akt
um dramatically sensitizes cells to sell
any sort of treatment by removing this
prominent pro-fitness consequence of
cellinexor so we see that across a panel
of AML cell lines treatment was
structurally and mechanistically
distinct akt Inhibitors leads to a
frequent
sensitization to cell anaxor
and we find that these results
um over time lead to a suppression of
outgrowth of selenix or treated AML cell
populations in vitro
this suppression of of outgrowth and
sensitization is associated with the
induction of mitochondrial apoptosis as
visualized by caspase and part cleavage
um and this this effect is dependent
upon not only the presence of backs
um uh but the but but also the
consequent activation of mitochondria
pertosis
the combination of akt inhibition in
cell and xor is synergistic not only in
cell line models but also in patient
Drive samples where approximately half
of a set of roughly 30 samples showed
Synergy in response to the combination
of therapy and another 16 of 32 samples
showed additivity suggesting that the
majority of amls are would be expected
to exhibit additivity or Synergy in the
in the presence of this combination
therapy
refreshingly we were relieved and happy
to see that normal hematoidic stem cells
did not show the same synergistic
response to cell next or plus akt
inhibitor combination therapies
suggesting that there may be a
therapeutic window in this combination
therapy between cancer cells and normal
cells
lastly we showed that in a panel of
robust
AML animal models the genetically
engineered Mouse model driven by MLL af9
the oci2 AML Celine xenograft model and
amlpdx model that in all three cases the
combination therapy substantially
extends overall Mouse survival compared
to cell next door treatment or akt
inhibition alone
and something that really excited us
um was that we found that in the in the
particularly aggressive MLL af9
genetically engineered Mouse model of
AML
um that the combination of cell and xor
um plus a pad assertive the akt
inhibitor not only outperforms um the
single agent therapies it performs it
outperforms
um a an optimized induction chemotherapy
regimen as well as the combination of
cell and xor plus chemotherapy uh and it
outperforms them by substantial margin
and this was particularly noteworthy to
us not only because
um induction chemotherapy is the
standard of care and young and healthy
patients with AML but also because the
cell and X4 plus a path sort of
combination therapy outperformed
induction chemotherapy even though it
was only administered for a few days
time in a manner that reflects the
administration of induction chemotherapy
this is noteworthy because we anticipate
that in an actual patient Sonics or plus
um uh pad assertive would actually be
administered on a chronic basis
now to move to the second story that I'm
going to share today
um in this case what we were really
interested in was looking not at The
Upfront drug treatment setting but
rather the setting of Frank acquired
resistance and specifically what we were
interested in
um was whether cells which develop
um resistance to a primary therapy might
exhibit hypersensitivity to new
therapies applied
this concept
um that the evolutionary changes that
lead to resistance to in or or
improved Fitness in one setting might
lead to a decrease in Fitness in another
setting is known as antagonistic
pleiotropy
um to understand the antagonistic
pleiotropy landscape in AML what we did
is we took oci aml2 cells and we
performed crispr screens either in the
presence of DMSO or in the presence of
of Eva each of a set of nine different
um approved and emerging AML
chemotherapies and targeted Therapies
for the case of each drug what we
documented through these screens were
genes and Pathways they can either
sensitize cells to that drug or confer
resistance to that drug
now if you look at the results from
these nine screens aggregated together
in a circus plot format what you can do
is you can focus in on genes shown in
red whose knockout confer sensitivity to
each drug or genes shown in teal whose
knockout converts resistance to each
drug
now what we were most interested in in
this study were genes whose loss
conferred sensitivity to certain drugs
but resistance to other drugs and the
the thinking here is that these would be
substrates for the development of
so-called chemotherapy-induced
evolutionary traps scenarios where
treatment of cells with one drug would
select for genetic alterations that
would also confer increased sensitivity
to a second judiciously applied drug
now when we look across all 36 pairs of
drugs examined in our studies in a
pairwise format
what we see is that some drugs share
large numbers of co-resistors or
co-sensitizers those would be those at
the top of this graph
whereas other drugs show large numbers
of of genes that exhibit antagonistic
pleiotropy meaning that they can confer
resistance to One Drug but sensitization
to another
perhaps not surprisingly
we found that drugs that work through
similar mechanisms of action like
decidabine and azocytodine
share share share large numbers of
common resistors and common sensitizers
like those shown here
amount more interesting to us though
were drugs on the other end of the
spectrum
drugs like jq1 the brd4 inhibitor and
ABT 199 or venetoclax the bcl2 inhibitor
which showed very different sensitivity
modifier Landscapes these drugs were
highly enriched for AP genes
scenarios where resistance to One Drug
convert hypersensitivity to another and
a great example of this is the cassette
of genes shown in here shown in in this
figure panel
as you can appreciate the loss of
certain of these genes causes
sensitivity to jq1 but resistance to ABT
or the reciprocal effect
now to dig in a little deeper what these
data led us to hypothesize was the
existence of a prc2 NSD Mick AP
signaling axis that controls sensitivity
and resistance to ABT 199 and jq1
specifically we hypothesized that nsd23
whose activation would be would be
assumed to activate Mick
we hypothesize that this because that
this arm of this cassette could drive
resistance to jq1 but sensitization to
abt199
and that correspondingly
um easy easy H2 and Eed which are
negative Regulators of Mick
um might be might be seen to observe to
confer resistance to 199 but sensitivity
to jq1
to sort of expand this idea we first
manipulated Mick itself and we showed
that knocking down make expression
indeed confers hypersensitivity to jq1
this is not surprising given that jq1 is
thought to act at least in part through
its suppression of Mick
um but that interestingly knockdown of
Mick conferred robust resistance to ABT
. similarly overexpression of Mick
confers resistance to jq1 and
sensitivity to 199.
now as evidence that the Upstream
members of this signaling cassette
indeed function through their effects on
Mick we show that NSD two or three
knockdown causes a suppression of mic
expression
um and sensitization to jq1
whereas knockdown of Eed or ezh2 causes
an increase in make expression and
sensitization instead to abt199
so together these data validate the
concept that make activation controlled
by the nsd2 and 3 and negatively
regulated by ezh2 and Eed can
differentially impact sensitivity to jq1
and to abt199
now to understand whether this um this
Gene cassette driven by Mick is
important in naturally evolved
resistance and not just functionally
contrived settings of resistance we
evolved a panel of five AML cell lines
to acquired resistance to the to the
brd4 inhibitor jq1
when we did this and then we looked at
the Western blotting level what we
observed is that in every setting cells
with acquired resistance to jq1 showed
increased levels of mic expression this
is again consistent with the idea that
mixed suppression is is critical to the
mechanism of action of this drug and
that Mick rebound would be an expected
mechanism of resistance
interestingly we also found that ezh2
loss in two of the five models was
observed coincident with Mick
hyperactivation suggesting that easy H2
loss might be actually be driving
resistance in these settings
um
in a manner that is expected given that
make us over activated in jq1 resistant
cells we found that these cells were
robustly sensitized to the bcl2
inhibitor venetoclax or abt199
and finally we showed that this
sensitization to ab2199 was dependent
upon the hyperactivation of Mick
specifically we showed that if you
suppress MC hyperactivation by partially
suppressing MC levels with shrna you
could completely reverse the ABT 199
hypersensitivity
the um uh
mix a promotion of hypersensitivity to
ABT 199 is driven by the fact that Mick
can cause apototic priming in cancer
cells this is not our Discovery this is
something that others have shown as well
but what we show is that in the setting
of
um of of Mick hyperactivation driven by
drug therapy in this case the by the
treatment with with the brd4 inhibitor
jq1 that this results in a in an
increase of cell priming State as
measured
um by bh3 profiling
and an increase in in Bim levels a a pro
apoptotic
member of the bcl2 family complex or a
family of epiotic regulators
in fact we showed this VM up regulation
is important
um for the hypersensitivity to ABT 199
that we observe in jq1 resistant cells
in that knocking down Bim partially
reverses the phenotype
lastly to understand whether the
acquisition of resistance to brd4
inhibition in Vivo leads to
hypersensitivity to bcl2 inhibition we
turn to a a PDX animal models
what we showed using bhc profiling and
the retrieval of cells and functional in
vitro assays is that while treatment
naive cells are
um modestly sensitive to ABT 199 therapy
that those cells that emerge following
treatment with jq1 with resistance to
jq1 exhibit hypersensitivity to ABT 199
therapy this validates the idea that the
treatment of cells initially with a brd4
inhibitor
primes uh an evolutionary trap
consistent with this idea we showed that
scheduling that drug therapies can
Impact Drug sensitivity specifically we
showed that a drug therapy that involved
first administering jq1 followed by
treatment with ABT 199 that's the bottom
scheme here is more effective at
suppressing leukemia levels in the body
then the reverse treatments treatment
schedule ABT 199 followed by jq1
we see this as read out by the total
number of AML cells in the bone marrow
as well as in the number of cd13 cd33
cells in the bone marrow suggesting the
idea that this therapy is leading to
Frank apoptosis
so in summary I hope what I've been able
to convey to you in this brief talk
um are are two stories that that
demonstrate how functional genomic
approaches can be used to better
understand how drugs work and in
particular to understand how to design
therapies that make drugs work better in
the first case by defining the
beneficial effects of drug therapies
such that those effects can be
neutralized and the second case by
defining how drug resistance can select
for clonal variants with increased
sensitivity to drugs that can be
exploited with well um with
well-designed evolutionary traps
in addition to the primary authors on
this work I want to acknowledge the
other scientists in my lab who are
performing studies in one way or another
related to these studies to better
understand how Cancer drugs work and how
these drug therapies can change Fitness
landscapes in cancer cells
and I also want to acknowledge our fund
the funding agencies that support our
work
with that thank you for your time today